joining us now with reaction is
Republican presidential candidate Vivek
ramaswamy Vivek it's so nice to be with
you and I'm very partial to people who
are known for their first name only
thanks for joining us thank you so
seriously speaking you know I on the
prize Joe Biden is the president I tell
people all the time it's very difficult
to dislodge a sitting president and so I
take seriously that we have to go beyond
showing the obvious mental and physical
deficits of this man and really hit him
hard on policy to dislodge him from the
presidency but Vivek if he is not going
to sort of show up the week that he
announces his re-election campaign how
how do you advise and how are you trying
to smoke them out
well look he's a not showing up for the
job that he's in B he's not showing up
in the job that he's signing up for for
the re-election campaign in the form of
debates but I think it all makes sense
Kelly and when you see that Joe Biden's
not really the one running for president
it is the managerial class that
conveniently puts him up as their puppet
and against that backdrop some of his
cognitive deficits that's not a bug it
is a feature and when you see it that
way I think what I'm going to go after
him on is even more than the policy the
fact that he's not even the person
running the government okay that
managerial bureaucracy actually controls
the president of the United States and
whether you're democrat or republican
you should want to live in a country
where the people who we elect to run the
government are the ones who actually run
the government same thing goes for the
Democratic National Committee that's why
they're hiding him from RFK or from
Marianne Williamson but I think it
represents the essence of what's
actually going on kellyanne is this is
the Deep State on steroids it's the
managerial class even within the
Democratic party that's why they're
shielding again it's very clear that
they're always trying to cling to power
and you mentioned RFK Jr and Marion
Williamson I'm really struck by their
Ascent in the polls pretty rapidly they
account for about a third right now of
all Democratic primary voters which is
pretty remarkable and they're not going
to get a chance it sounds to debate Joe
Biden for that nomination I mean you go
back for a year eight years ago and
Donald Trump four years ago Donald Trump
was being assailed by people who are one
percent two percent one guy was an
asterisk and the New York Times was
obsessed with covering his campaign
every other page these people have
they've broken a threshold that really
has gained them their rightful place on
a debate stage but as you know they're
afraid to debate Biden they're actually
afraid to have them show up but Vivek
let me ask you a question about Joe
Biden's position even in his own party a
majority Democrats don't want him to run
it's very clear that he is running he
announces re-election he announced it
very differently than you did he put out
a video where he did didn't have a
positive optimistic view of America he
didn't brag about his own
accomplishments he didn't give a
forward-looking hope and change to point
a phrase from President Obama that kind
of message but I want to ask you what
does it tell you about the Democratic
party right now that a Joe Biden is his
leader and B they're afraid to have
people debate him for the nomination
seems very anti-competitive
anti-democratic
well it is for Democratic party that
preaches about our democracy it's not a
very Democratic thing to do to hide from
debate this is why the Republican Party
can lead the way in being better Kelly
and I think that this is our moment as a
Republican party to say that we are the
party of free speech and open debate we
Embrace that because that's what our
founding culture as a country was based
on and when I look at the criticisms
that Marian Williamson and RFK are
leveling against Biden to me the
dividing line in this country right now
isn't even between Democrats and
Republicans it is between the managerial
class in this country and the everyday
Citizen and when you view it that way I
think it makes a lot more sense that
Biden is representative of the
managerial class in this country but I
think free speech and open debate the
Democratic party would be better off
they're spitting in the face of their
own Base by saying that they're not even
going to give them the opportunity to
challenge the guy who's in charge this
is an opportunity for the GOP we can
practice what we preach I intend to be
on that debate stage age so I tell
people to go to vivek2024.com join the
movement that's going to make our party
better our movement better in our
country better and I think it's going to
be the formula for a landslide election
for Republicans if we practice what we
preach you were complimented today on
Truth social by former president Trump
he noted your position in the polls
clearly you're right now you're clearing
that one percent threshold that's been
put forth for the debates so let me ask
you it's a year and a half only 18 short
months from the next presidential
election bring us into your
Administration Who's name a couple
people would be in your cabinet your
senior staff
well we're evaluating who we're going to
put out it's going to be a combination
of people who come from outside of
government I do think we need some fresh
blood but also some people who have seen
how you take on the administrative
bureaucracy and the Deep state I'm
focused on day one executive orders
kellyanne not the things that I want to
drive through Congress I think that's a
lot of presidents make a lot of the
mistakes that time trying to go through
Congress I want to focus on rescinding
affirmative action which you can do by
executive order because Lyndon Johnson
did it by executive order I want to
focus on shutting down agencies like the
Department of Education that should have
never existed executive orders to
actually roll back any mandate to report
carbon emissions that's how you unlock
the economy and so one of the things I'm
focused on is actually what can a
president do without asking anybody for
permission and asking anybody for
forgiveness and that way Congress is
designed to move slowly we'll get to
that later but the first three months of
my Administration are going to be all
about executive power constitutionally
scoped putting the military on the
southern border to secure the Border
those are the kinds of things the U.S
president can do including as
commander-in-chief and that's where my
focus is kellyanne well I'm like Joe
Biden I think when Canada's like you put
forth specifics and solutions you're
respecting the brains and the hearts of
the voters and you're giving them a
voice and a choice in the process that's
what this is all about executive power
of course we watched president Trump do
that on day one President Biden of
course on day one just kill those
Keystone Pipeline jobs out of spite
that's what he did that was his priority
Vivek ramaswamy thank you so much for
joining me